whoever said cartridge-based gaming is
dead is probably right but the classic
gaming brand koliko may resurface in the
near future with help from retro video
game systems incorporated the pair will
soon launch a new Kickstarter campaign
to fund the launch of the Calico
chameleon console which comes hot on the
heels of the failed IndieGoGo campaign
for the retro vgs console a near
identical product from retro video game
systems inc that failed to meet its
two-hundred-thousand-dollar goal last
month the chameleon is described as a
versatile new video game system that
serves as a modern-day take on the
classic gaming console it can play 8 16
and 32 bit games which koliko Holdings
says is a growing in popular genre
koliko holdings is a subsidiary of
riverwest brands who purchased the
rights to the koliko name from Hasbro
the Kaliko chameleon marks the first new
console that can play cartridges in two
decades Mike Kennedy retro video game
systems president describes it as a love
letter to all the classic
cartridge-based game systems that came
before he added it will take gamers and
their families back to a simpler time
when games were all about great gameplay
and fun factor the original colecovision
console was released in 1982 then the
original koliko company went bankrupt in
1988 and shortly after Hasbro acquired
most of his assets posting to Twitter
the developers assured fans and those
who are interested that it will be
significantly more affordable than the
first go around the Calico chameleon
will be available for purchase in early
2016 if the campaign is successful